Yeah,
that was stated by the famous Harvard
University economics professor Edward
Glaeser cities czar,
one of humanity's great creations.
Cities.
They make us retro greener,
healthier,
happier.
If you are,
over time,
cities have become a synonym for freedom
and prosperity.
Of course,
they are in precisely a new phenomenon
since human beings stopped wandering
from place to place in search of food.
About 10,000
years ago,
they began to build settlements that
over time became cities and it was
finally in the third millennium BC.
The great city states began to emerge in
the Mesopotamian region.
City is like,
oh my gosh,
Umar and it's the most popular one.
Babylon today,
5,000
years later,
more than half of the world's population
lives in cities,
and by the way,
more than 500 of those cities have more
than 1 million inhabitant.
There's no doubt about it.
The Great Take off of urbanism happens
in the 19th century with the industrial
revolution.
Since then,
we've lived in a state of constant
urbanization,
a process that has so far in deodorants
switch.
While it doesn't look like it's going to
stop anytime soon.
See,
the United Nations predict that by the
year 2050 almost 70% of the entire
world's population will live in cities.
What began in what we now know is
developed countries and since the mid
20th century extended to developing
countries has led to a world dominated
by huge metropolises.
Well,
one second.
what exactly is the influence of big
cities?
She wants him revealing facts.
Well,
here they are.
It's estimated that only the 600 most
dynamic cities in the world where 23% of
the planet's population lives generates
55% of all economic activity in a few
years.
That figures is going to exceed 60% in
other words,
our wells and our way of life depends
more and more on cities.
Cities off of the World Watch Messi
might be if a boss Ilona,
and this is a new phenomenon,
has emerged from this huge evolution,
and that's mega cities.
These are metropolises with more than 10
million inhabitants nowadays.
There are no less than 43 of these on
the planet and so check this out.
They all the places that are growing the
most in developing countries,
and this presents a huge challenge.
In fact,
it causes so many problems that it's
setting off major alarm bells allow me
to explain.
In the poorest countries in the world,
cities are growing at a frantic and
completely uncontrolled pace,
which is generating very high levels of
pollution,
crime as chaotic traffic.
Many of the new mega cities,
they've simply devolved into chaos.
For example,
check out these headlines from air
pollution closes all schools in Tehran.
New Delhi is once again the most
polluted city on earth.
At this point,
you might have several questions.
Where will the most populated cities in
the world be in a few decades?
What would be their future?
And most importantly,
what challenges do these new mega cities
face?
Well,
let's see.
New Giants,
I'm sorry.
Then unfortunately I have an assignment
for you.
You're going to need to learn and
remember some new city names because
folks,
most of the new mega cities,
they arms even household names.
Yet a recent study by the Ontario
Institute of Technology as indicators
for the,
by the end of this century,
we can expect the largest cities not to
be places like Tokyo,
Mexico City,
New York,
but rather legos can Shasta and Dar es
Salaam.
Yes,
you heard that right?
Future mega cities will be among other
places in Africa.
Surprise.
While you shouldn't be at least if you
follow visual politic regularly on this
channel,
and we've already mentioned several
times how the African continent is
changing.
Okay.
Did that study by the Institute of
Technology of Ontario,
these three cities located in Nigeria,
the Congo in Tanzania,
which are expected to be the largest
cities in the world,
could surpass the 75 million inhabitant
mark by the end of the century.
75 million people is a truly enormous
figure.
If this happens,
just one of these cities would have more
inhabitants than all of Germany today.
You
crazy,
right,
but hold on a second because we really
don't need to go that far into the
future.
It's estimated that by the year 2050 and
that's really not that far away.
If the five largest metropolitan areas
on the planet will be these places,
check it out.
Yeah.
Three
Lindsay,
I wanted Bangladesh ends another in the
Congo.
The largest of all of them will have
more than 40 million inhabitants.
Now,
as you can imagine,
this poses a great deal of challenges.
If today,
many of these cities already have huge
problems,
imagine what it will be like in a few
years.
Let's see exactly what we're dealing
with here.
The challenges
folks,
the case of Legos,
Nigeria as larger city,
it's actually kind of amazing.
In the 1960s this city barely had
180,000
inhabitants.
It looked like a small western style
coastal town and it was surrounded by
small villages.
Today it's got more than 20 million
inhabitants and it's simply when you
stop growing according to an existing
estimates,
this city is destined to become the most
populated place on the planet.
By the end of the century,
it could have more than 90 million
inhabitants,
but there's an important point when we
talk about mega cities.
It's normal to think of huge
skyscrapers,
super imposed transport systems into
gigantic avenues.
However,
today in most cases,
the reality is very,
very different.
Sorry,
Z with more than 20 million inhabitants.
Sligo since become a collapsed labyrinth
of cars and motorcycles,
a place where power outages or frequence
and public services such as water supply
and waste collection and treatments when
they exist,
fail more often than a silicon valley
startup.
And of course most of the population
they live in crowded,
substandard housing and others in misery
because of course this excessive city
growth,
it poses two kinds of problems.
One directly related to infrastructure
ends.
Can the other with the social and
political consequences that didn't
involve
managing a city in excess of 50 million
inhabitants,
is it daunting task,
especially as many of these cities are
woefully under serviced today?
65 years is a relatively short timeframe
with regard to urban infrastructure.
Much of it,
for example,
London Underground and brome streets as
long lived and can take decades to
develop.
Daniel Horn wag and Kevin Pope
see recently a United Nations study
about Manila,
the capital city of the Philippines,
and one of the fastest growing cities in
the world.
Documents at a myriad of problems
related to waste management's according
to this study,
garbage piles up in the streets and
drainage problems and generating all
kinds of infectious outbreaks.
Another study also from the United
Nations warns that in Mumbai,
the second most popular city in India is
one that exceeds the 20 million and the
habits and barrier,
but substandard housing and shacks are
crowded on top of one another and the
streets aren't even finished,
and in many cases,
they're not even paved.
Making them flood in the monsoon season,
which doesn't do any calls,
huge amounts of destruction,
but the water ends up stagnating and
spreading diseases.
Then there's the pollution.
Many of these cities are among the most
polluted in the world and we already saw
in a previous video just how much wealth
and pollution are related and the
problems they don't end there.
This uncontrolled growth is also forcing
a large part of the population to live
in neighborhoods and areas where they
don't only lack of basic services,
but also important institutions like the
police.
This is something that favors the spread
of Matthews and all kinds of criminal
and radical groups.
That's precisely what mega cities like
San Pablo,
Rio de Janeiro and Mexico City are
experiencing folks in sale now.
The great metropolises of always been a
source of wealth and prosperity that of
course there's no reason to think that
it's going to be any different this time
around.
Yeah.
No country in the industrial era
achieved any significant economic growth
without urbanization.
Cities concentrate poverty,
but the also represent the main hope for
getting out of it.
You end state of the world population
2007 right report.
Okay.
Cities have always been the center of
knowledge,
technological and artistic advances and
new ideas.
Even at the political level,
people who live in cities.
I've traditionally had a more open
vision and I've been more tolerance and
receptive to change.
However,
with the emergence of these new mega
cities in a world of cities,
it looks like we're facing a challenge
with two possible outcomes.
First that these new urban giants will
bolster the local economy,
generate new ways of creating wealth,
promote civil liberties,
and in the end be seen as the equals of
cities like Tokyo,
New York,
London.
The second outcome is that these cities
will continue to grow in population
without any substantial infrastructure
improvements and that case the sum of
misery,
pollution and violence because ended up
creating new radical politicians or
driving new refugee waves towards the
more developed countries.
Well,
I'm sure you're not surprised,
but we on this channel like to think
that it will be the first.
We'd like to think that these new mega
cities will contribute to a better world
in the near future as well as in the
long term,
but for that they won't only need
solidarity and to aid above all,
they're going to need a lot of
investments anyways,
folks will be looking forward to all of
these changes and I really hope you
enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos,
sorts of,
don't forget to check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media
podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine.
Also,
there's channel possible because of
Patriarchy and our patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage,
and as always,
thank you for it.